[موسيقى]
يا
kkoma هو مجتمع فريد جدًا
لدينا مليون ونصف ساكن تحت الأرض
و 1711 خطرًا
أصبحنا مدينة السيوف
[موسيقى]
اسمي بات هاتفيلد وأنا
مؤرخ متقاعد لمدينة
كولمان
الأول  لقد ظهر القليل منذ 65 عامًا
منذ عام 1950 ، لدينا الآن 17 مقبرة
أسميها الأمم المتحدة أو
السكرتارية لأن لدينا مقبرة
لكل شخص لدينا على سبيل المثال
لدينا أربع مقابر يهودية لدينا
مقبرة كاثوليكية ومقبرة يونانية في
تلك المقبرة المحتضرة
[موسيقى
] ولدينا أيضًا سكرتير للحيوانات الأليفة ،
لدينا أشياء جدًا مثل وايت
إيرب وجو ديماجيو وويليام
راندولف هيرست ، وقد
ورثنا مئات الآلاف من الجثث
لأنه أثناء اندفاع
الذهب ، جاء العديد من عمال مناجم الذهب إلى هنا ومعهم  لقد
اشتروا الكثير من الأمراض ، حيث كان في سان
فرانسيسكو مؤخرًا 27
مقبرة وكانت ممتلئة ، وقال آباء المدينة إن
أراضينا مخصصة للأحياء وليس
للموتى ، لذلك يعلم الإخلاء أنه قد تم تجاوزه.
عام 1914 وتم نقل الجثث
هنا ببطء لتهدأ في الزاوية ،
يحترم السكان حقًا مقابرنا ،
لكننا نسمي حدائق العلامات ، هذا
ما نحن عليه في نزهة ، ثم نسير فيها ،
أطفالنا يلعبون بها ، إنهم مجرد
جزء منا لدينا.  نبض أبطأ
هنا يكاد يموت
[موسيقى]